16:03 in Queen Elizabeth the first of
England is dead since she had no
children the throne pass to the nearest
available male Protestant heir James the
sixth of Scotland the first monarch of
the House of Stuart by this point he was
36 married with two sons and had to deal
with the difficulties that came with
running three kingdoms the most pressing
issue was war with Spain which James was
keen to end and did so in 1604 James's
accession was fairly uneventful barring
the main plot which is one of the two
plots which sought to overthrow him it
notably led to the arrest of Sir Walter
Raleigh the noted explorer who was at
first sentenced to death but this was
commuted to life in prison
James's reign marks the beginning of
what is known as the union of the
Crown's England and Scotland were still
distinct entities with their own
Parliament's but since Kings controlled
foreign policy meant that they would no
longer go to war with each other the
England which James inherited was one
which had over the past half a century
seen continuous population growth from
about 3 million to about 4.2 million
agriculture couldn't keep up the price
of food skyrocketed and so his early
reign saw some famines but after this
mass hunger largely disappeared from
England those who struggled relied on
the Elizabethan pall rate which was a
system of poor relief which gave things
like food wood for fuel and clothing to
the poor
this led many to move from rural areas
to the city continuing the trend of
increasing urbanization cities had been
growing steadily since the early chuda
period five of which had populations
over 10,000 by the time James took the
throne unsurprisingly London was the
largest boasting a population of about
200,000 which dwarfed England's second
city Norwich whose population was only
15,000 one of the great issues facing
James at his secession was the same as
his predecessors religion in 1604 the
Hampton Court conference was called to
answer a petition by Puritans and decide
on any outstanding matters of doctrine
James was actually fairly responsive to
the Puritans who began to work within
the structures of the church to achieve
the reforms they wanted instead of
simply moaning all of the time the most
important outcome of the conference was
that it saw work begin on the authorized
English translation of the Bible better
known as the King James Bible which
wasn't completed until 1611 the
religious divide in England was not
something that could be fixed by a
simple conference there were divisions
amongst the Protestants particularly
between the Puritans and a newer group
called the arminians which split the
ruling classes
furthermore James quickly began to
punish rikugien see which was when a
catholic refused to abide by the rules
of the Church of England James had made
his position perfectly clear which had -
the Catholics hope of a more moderate
monarch
to what was probably the most famous
event of his reign the Gunpowder Plot
the Gunpowder Plot was a conspiracy by
13 men the two most notable being so
Robert Catesby the ringleader and Guy
Fawkes to block the houses of parliament
was the king was addressing it the
reasons for the plot aren't definitively
known but it was probably an attempt by
hardline Catholics to kill a Protestant
King is reprisal for their persecution
famously King James wasn't blown up and
Guy Fawkes was discovered with a bunch
of gun powder underneath Parliament and
arrested he was subsequently tortured
into revealing his accomplices who were
shortly afterwards captured and executed
the next year James in Parliament passed
harsh laws against Catholics but there
was no intense persecution because he
didn't want to upset the Catholic powers
of Europe too much James also sought the
creation of stringent anti witchcraft
laws which banned people from making
pacts with the devil
most of those accused of witchcraft were
old single women but men were accused
too
courts were actually very skeptical of
the accusation of witchcraft and
convictions weren't hugely common a
couple of years later saw a major event
in the history of England in the world
the first permanent English settlement
in North America at Jamestown in what is
now Virginia the English had tried
before with the colony at Roanoke but it
failed the next year would also see
James appoint commissioners to oversee
another colonial project the plantations
in Ireland these plantations were where
the Irish were kicked off of their land
and it was given to English and Scottish
Protestant settlers to live on instead
the idea was that this would make
Ireland less prone to revolt since the
native Irish would be poor and that
eventually the Protestants would
outnumber the Catholics fun fact
didn't work James like a lot of monarchs
was also having financial troubles and a
man called Robert Cecil the Lord High
treasurer had attempted to balance his
books he couldn't so in 1610 he asked
Parliament to levy taxes to help the
King which Parliament refused a
compromise was instead proposed called
the great contract which would see the
king forfeit certain privileges in
return for an annual allowance
ultimately the great contract failed
because it meant that the king would no
longer have to ask parliament for money
which meant independence and also nobody
knew where the money would come from
James soon after dissolve Parliament in
a huff and most of the next decade was
fairly stable barring a few things in
1612 Cecil died leaving a major
competency gap in government and in the
same year James eldest son Henry died
leaving Prince Charles's heir in 1614
James could another Parliament called
the addled Parliament due to it being
completely pointless James wanted more
money Parliament wasn't so sure and so
he gave up in 1616 Sir Francis Bacon was
appointed Lord treasurer and in 1618 Sir
Walter Reilly was released on the
condition that he find El Dorado
he doesn't during his voyage to find
this non-existent city Reilly attacked
the Spanish
which James had specifically forbidden
him to do so and upon his return he was
beheaded 1618 was also a big year for
European history since its war the
outbreak of the incredibly destructive
30 Years War but it didn't really kick
off until 1620 in this same year
Plymouth Colony was founded in North
America by the pilgrims who were a bunch
of radical Puritans that felt that the
Church of England was corrupt and so
they were out so James is seen by many
as a peacemaker since he disliked war
and saw it only as the last resort
his reasons for staying out at the war
despite England being Europe's most
populous Protestant powell were largely
diplomatic and financial because war is
expensive
James was trying to get his son and heir
Charles to marry the daughter of the
king of Spain in return for a large
dowry because he needed the money and
also wanted to ensure peace with Spain
Parliament and Prince Charles disagreed
with the policy of peace and wanted war
with Spain because glory was better than
financial stability
generally speaking the ministers who
favored war were Puritans those who
hadn't left for America anyway and those
who favored peace were the Armenians
whilst they couldn't agree on war they
did agree on one thing the Prince
Charles shouldn't marry a Catholic in
case you're wondering this immense
paranoia and distrust surrounding
Catholics isn't going anywhere as king
though James was in firm control of
foreign policy and so never declared war
on Spain for the rest of his reign which
ended with his death in 1625 he was
succeeded by Charles who was crowned
Charles the first his King James was
open to suggestions and understood the
nuances of political life Charles did
not his abrasive authoritarian attitude
combined with the fact that his court
favorite George Vili a the Duke of
Buckingham was corrupt meant the
parliament to many of the nobility fell
out with the new king pretty quickly so
upon the accession of a king Parliament
would grant them what was called the
customs whereby the king could collect
custom duties on certain goods for their
personal revenue this time Parliament
decided no but Charles collected them
anyway furthermore Charles declared war
on Spain but he pledged that it would
remain a naval war the first action was
a raid on Cadiz here and to say that it
was a failure would be a colossal
understatement
meanwhile in the rest of Europe the
English and Scottish contributions to
the 30 Years War were small it was
mostly Scottish mercenaries who worked
for the Danish and later Swedish forces
but generally speaking the finances
weren't available for any large-scale
intervention in order to raise the funds
needed to continue fighting Charles went
to Parliament but they refused to grant
him these funds until Buckingham was
impeached due to him being terrible
Charles was furious about this and so he
blocked Buckinghams impeachment and
raised money through what is called a
forced loan this was where the King
demanded that his subjects lend him
money during
emergency and if you refused you'd find
yourself up in front of a court also it
wasn't much of a loan because good luck
getting it back
the threats worked and Charles raise
enough revenue but managed to annoy
everyone in the process to make matters
worse Buckingham used this money to
assist the prostitutes in France which
led to France declaring war in England
these wars didn't achieve anything
except proving that Buckingham was
incompetent and ruining England
financially Buckingham would retire from
politics in 1628 and by retire I mean he
was stabbed to death angry with the
murder of his favorite and believing
that Parliament was acting against him
unfairly Charles dissolved it in 1629
beginning his personal rule without a
parliament to levy taxes Charles had
limited means to raise money of which he
had too little he did this by trudging
up old feudal laws that nobody had heard
of and finding people for not adhering
to them he also levied what was called
[ __ ] money which was where coastal
regions were expected to provide ships
on the money for them to the King for
the defence of England this was
challenged in court it being argued that
this was a tax and thus only Parliament
had the authority to raise it the court
ended up siding with the king and
afterwards he extended it to all of the
inland counties and made a fair bit of
money from doing so
in 1633 Charles appointed a man could
William Lord as the Archbishop of
Canterbury who wanted to make some
changes to the Church of England that
were pretty upsetting to the faithful
and in particular the Puritans the
Puritans were opposed to the idea of
there being a clergy who they believed
had no right to stand between faithful
believers in God they also felt that
there were too many rituals which they
considered to be superstitious and to
Catholic so Lord and Charles believed
that Kings were an earthly
representative of God and that his
subjects were supposed to obey him
without question Lord also sought to add
more mystery and decoration to church
ceremony which led to some anxiety
amongst the laity in the nobles who fit
that England was creeping back towards
Catholicism for many Puritans the
changes were too much and so they
decided to leave places like Boston and
head to North America where they founded
Boston Puritans were not the most
inventive Bunch in the same year as
Lords Appointments I was appointed
Thomas Wentworth as Lord deputy of
Ireland whose job it was to subdue the
Irish and impose stricter English rule
wentworths rule was harsh and he made
promises to all groups that he couldn't
keep her managed to unite all of Ireland
against him which was frankly impressive
the plan was to destroy Catholicism in
Ireland to begin further plantations
here in Connaught which had been spared
up until now this never happened because
Charles was having an issue with his
Nobles in Scotland so Charles had
attempted to introduce a modified book
of Prayer into the Scottish Church which
upset basically everyone who saw it as
an attempt to make Scotland England
a movement in opposition to this formed
the Covenant is who demanded that these
changes be reversed and furthermore the
bishops were useless and needed to go
Charles ever the diplomat decided the
force would settle this and so raised an
army beginning the bishops war in 1639
the Scottish army which contained many
veterans of the 30 Years War was much
better prepared basically no fighting
happened and Charles agreed to what is
called the pacification of barrack in
which it was decided that another
Scottish Church assembly would decide on
the fate of bishops this assembly met in
Glasgow and declared that they were free
of any and all rule control and so
Charles decided that yet again force
would fix this Charles decided to fight
Anne in order to obtain the funds to
crush the Scottish he would need to
recall the English Parliament and end
his 11 year personal rule he did this in
1640 but what came next wouldn't be easy
in Charles's reign would only get more
difficult from here on out but more on
that next episode I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette for sponsoring the channel
if you'd like to know more about the
early Stuart's and the reigns of James
and Charles the first then there are
some book recommendations in the
description below
you